it's day one of the three-day trip for
the afghan delegation led by the foreign
minister oslo is the first place in
europe after trips to russia iran qatar
china and pakistan
but norway has made it clear that this
does not mean legitimacy for the taliban
but a chance to talk to those who are in
charge of afghanistan
in norway we have a meeting with the us
and also with the european union on
matters of mutual interest
one part of our meetings would be with
our afghan diaspora who are outside the
country especially in europe their ideas
consultations and plans will be heard
this means that meetings for mutual
understanding will continue between
afghans
during the closed doors meetings at a
local hotel economic business and
political issues are high on the agenda
the west is looking to use its leverage
of sanctions frozen afghan money and
humanitarian aid while the interim
government wants money legitimacy and
removal from banned lists
the focus from outside remains on
pressing taliban leaders on their
promises to deliver women's rights girls
education and civil liberties
taliban leaders trying to move from a
fighting force to a governing council
have yet to deliver on a countrywide
secondary education for girls but have
allowed women to work in hospitals
schools and airports
they deny arresting women and cracking
down on activists while some women
continue to protest and demand their
rights very often in the absence of that
communication the international
community or different stakeholders keep
moving the goal post so in order to make
sure that the taliban are
the words that they're putting out there
are aligning with their actions and
women and disenfranchised groups in
general in afghanistan are protected um
that's going to be a
huge outcome if that can come out of or
we can start headed in that direction
from norway
the harsh winter is yet another strain
for most afghans who have not been paid
for months and struggling with a
collapsing economy
and the biggest test for taliban leaders
is to keep the population fed and warm
aid agencies warn a million afghan
children could face starvation
that's despite the united nations
providing money to pay for salaries and
importing essentials like wheat and
electricity
taliban officials insist they seek peace
and won't let afghanistan become a
security concern
but they say in order for it to function
as a state the international community
must release 10 billion dollars of
afghan money frozen abroad to get the
economy going and address humanitarian
needs
osama bin laden al jazeera